hi this is preshtalwalker here's a
mathematical problem that's related to
american football
suppose a to b is an impossible nfl
score
solve for the values of a and b in fact
consider the value which maximizes a
plus b
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
according to the rules of nfl football a
team can score two three six seven or
eight points
but we don't need to consider all of the
different ways
we can just focus on two and three for
this problem
a team can score using two and three
points it could score four points by
scoring two points two times
they could also score five points as a
combination of scoring three points and
then two points
it could also score six points by
scoring three points two times
now we can consider this triplet of
numbers
and if we add three to four points
a team can score seven points in the
following fashion
if we add three points to five points we
can score eight points and if we add
three points to six points we can score
nine points
we can repeat this process if we look
consider the triplets seven eight nine
if we add three points to each one of
these equations we'll find out a team
can score 10 11 and 12 points
now we can clearly repeat this process
and we can show that it's possible to
reach every single point total that's
larger than two
and this is related to a mathematical
problem
the coin problem or the chicken mcnugget
problem says that if a and b are whole
numbers that are relatively prime
then the largest impossible score or the
largest impossible denomination
that you can get just by adding the
values and multiples of those values is
a times b
minus a minus b
in the nfl problem we have two and three
which are relatively prime because their
largest factor is one
so the largest impossible score would be
two times three minus two minus three
which is one
so that means the largest point total
that cannot be achieved is one
so if one team scores a and another team
scores b
we know that a and b can at most be one
so we have a and b can at most be one we
could also have zero so there are only
four possibilities for an impossible
score zero zero one zero zero one and
one one
it's possible that a game could end in a
draw no team scores at all
the last time this happened was 1943 but
it's possible so zero zero is not an
impossible score
the only impossible scores are one zero
zero one and one one
of these one one
is the value that maximizes a plus b so
it's the largest impossible score
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon
you can catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker
and if you like this video please check
out my books there are links in the
video description